hello everyone and welcome to the
triumphant return of the friday game
review I didn't a game that was
unrehearsed yeah I'm eme Lewis as always
with me is Dan Galpin and today I'm
actually wearing a cheesehead it's about
time Dan Galpin I don't know if I've
really made this clear because we make
fun of Dan a lot on the show ha ha dan
walks among mortals as a coding /
developer relations god someone who can
only be expressed in it with the
headgear I just I thought it was the
fact that i'm generally cheesy wherever
I go actually what it is is dan is so
good at what he does that he basically
just lift a middle finger to the world
and it's silly fashion requirements
right exactly Oh check that out a
producer rato now has two cameras to
work with and that's Trevor 12 oh nice
that's exciting unfortunately camera two
is apparently not lit at all no it's not
work on that yeah what get light
actually bouncing off of us towards
camera too although realistically that's
not my best angle really good ah you
have a good angle at no but I have I've
ones that are better worse than others
ok joining us as well is uh yeah i've
been i've been taunted by the mystery
beer for several hours now so yep
alright so I'm it actually came in this
this wrapper although I turned it inside
out so you wouldn't be able to tell what
it is okay ready all right okay if it
bottoms up hmm that's pretty haughey
yeah that's it that's pretty
significantly a bitter eyes I like eight
that is uh so this is another from our
friends at how fantastic the yes the
mckellar and 1000 i bu and just to to
put that in context i think most IPAs
top out at ironic
100 yeah that's actually you know it's
quite good and it's powerful I think
that I think they want me to point a
bitterness we're just can't get any
bitter yeah well you know basically I
we've spent the last six months or so
building up a tolerance to all things
bitter here and that's true yeah so it's
it's I I've been working with you for a
year yes that's true but that's that's
me building up a tolerance to things
better God all right all right so let's
uh let's get right on to the game so
we've got some really interesting things
too we've got a few games that came off
the the moderator that we're going to
look at thanks for voting yeah thank you
very much for voting uh sorry to
everyone who's games were not chosen
there were some comments today on the
Friday review google+ page talking about
why certain things were were not voted
in so i just wanted to clear that up the
reason that something will get chosen is
a because you vote it up and be because
we want to talk about it so typically
rato and i will sit down and look at the
top 10 apps and the top 10 games and
rato will choose some number of apps
from that of which he'll cover maybe
three and and then dan i will sit down
and look at the games and look at the
top ten and choose usually the top six
we generally try to just choose the top
voted games but we don't always and
usually it's because one of the top
voted games is something we just don't
have much to say about and i'm
particularly looking at you x bugs dude
we talked about your thing twice man so
quit it with a complaining because we're
not going to talk about it again good
game we did actually nominate it we did
I absolutely get a lot of times a
nomination will take four to five weeks
to go through and the reason is that
merchandising has a whole pile of apps
that could be featured and then they'll
choose the ones that they think are
going to be
best for that particular week yeah as
with ax bugs itself I'm vaguely remember
some comment that squashing bugs is not
as fun as they thought it was going to
be but you know that's that that that
just might be you know their therapy Nia
but I I thought that washing bugs was
quite a lot of fun I thought it was
endless fun I wouldn't get out of the
whole family it was you know it was
something that that that small children
would appreciate in it's a lot nicer
than having them squash real bugs so
yeah you know in general oh it's a bug
squashing simulator they're gonna go out
and squash bugs all weekend long as soon
as they get away from me the reader
their mutant bugs all right now we've
talked about a good boy all right shoot
alright so let's we're also going to
talk about some games that weren't
actually nominated because Ian and I had
something miraculous happened in the
last yes we actually had a few days off
yes following did boy do I regret it the
first moment I opened up my email inbox
and so we actually had some time to play
games that were not on the moderator
list and so we want to talk about some
of the games we've been playing some of
them last week some of them throughout
the last couple of months and and you
know put them through the same kind of
critical filter as we put everything
else on the friday game review through
and and also we want to talk a little
bit about some of the things that have
gone on in the last few weeks one of
course is today we are shipping next to
seven devices which is on my way today
today oh yeah and this is surprised me
because none of us knew actually a lot
of people are like oh wise google so
secretive you know why won't they say
when they're shipping thing because we
don't know yeah pretty much i'm sure
somebody does we don't we post the only
reason i know is that we posted it on a
Google+ page and and so there you go
like all right well I guess we're
shipping devices how seriously if you
and I ever get fired will probably find
out about it from the public ah yes
that's how we find out everything okay I
guess I should pack up my desk exactly
alright so so anyway yeah so nexus 7
lyssa let's bring that bad boy up this
is an awesome game machine and i'll tell
you why so first it's got the the Tegra
3 inside yeah so very similar to our
previous standby which is the ACS
transformer prime now actually we're
still going to use the Asus Transformer
Prime on the show and the reason is that
it has one of the best hdmi output
implementations that we've ever seen
absolutely whereas the nexus 7 stock
does not come with an hdmi output at all
but i'm playing games on this and i'll
tell you why mmm because it's just as
fast and it's easier to hold the truth
is that having a in fact if rato would
go to camera two for a second um when
you have the the ability to just hold it
in your hands like this you know
compared to write they going to talk
especially yeah you might want to take
the dock off I want we'll talk is so
cool Wow all right what yeah all right
so for some definitions are cool anyways
the way you hold it in your hands like
this it's just really easy i can play
accelerometer games I can play
dual-stick games and I never get tired
of holding it and I never feel like I
have to stretch my thumbs to reach
element to the interface but at the same
time I never feel like I'm squinting
because it's so much bigger than a phone
yeah it's an awesome game playing device
and you know that's where I've been
doing pretty much all of the gaming that
I that I don't do on Galaxy Nexus these
days and and you know they're there are
I'm just excited for more game
developers to get their hands on it I
think it's fantastic like we finally
have a development platform that anyone
can go and buy this running the latest
version of Android you know that
hopefully will be available at some
point to everyone around the world but
today it's available to a lot of people
so that's really cool yeah and at a very
good price point to yeah and jay is
awesome that I don't watch so we're not
we're not actually talking about you
know what we're talking about this we're
actually really not trying to pimp this
as a sales pitch we actually let's try
me we are just really excited about it
yeah I just want to make it really clear
that you know that this is not our this
is the official nexus 7 commercial
segment of the friday game review this
is because we freaking love playing
games of this device I mean I what it
comes down to yeah and you know Paul and
here's the thing yeah Jay jellybeans
jellybeans oh my god yeah project butter
is awesome and yeah actually sink the
vsync in your games is awesome everyone
should start doing it it's really really
cool and
and we may even cover that someday I
don't know maybe in another form yeah we
know we've had some really good talks
about that um in general the
improvements that we made in jellybean
will make your user experience totally
smooth you you will feel like you bought
a new device like I put it on my galaxy
nexus I felt like I just gotten a new
phone yeah I i think it's it's finally
gotten to be you know what i would
consider world class because you know i
think we could admit that gingerbread
and even ICS were genki compared to what
we really wanted you know from the
hardware of what the hardware is capable
of yeah I mean I fixed all of that
actually we've gone beyond with the
hardware's capable of right now you know
that's it no I all seriousness with what
what's great about Jay for gamers is
that is it our touch response has gone
from two to three frames worth of delay
to really one frame yep fixed delay
which is amazing and so you have we've
actually seen significant performance
improvements in some games yeah just for
running on jelly in the interesting
thing is we have no idea why yeah it's a
complete mystery to us we're gonna
figure that out one day to ya this this
is the ultimate temple run machine I can
tell you that's right temple run brave
got what 10 or 15 percenters um clean
bizarre yeah it was as a Unity game yeah
should we see that on any other unis
titles I've invited to go to a total
read brave knight it's like to put the
best the best part about it is that is
that your your gestures just get get
recognized just that much better and
it's just it really looks awesome so I'm
really excited I can't wait to hear what
you guys think of it when you get your
hands on it and and let's go on to some
games yeah let's do that so yeah this is
a very special episode of the friday
game review and i'm pretty sure when I
posted that at least some people they
grew up in the 70s and 80s thought that
it was going to be about us kicking our
drug habits and it's not those habits
are very valuable to us absolutely yeah
but let's go ahead and take a look at
some of the game why don't we start with
one of the games that you've been
playing all right so I not to be you
know completely cliche here but I've
been playing a lot of dead trigger and
and this is this is dead trigger I'm
actually getting getting wiped right now
running here on the transformer prime
and this is not my real game I will
point out that I'm up 2day like 70 on
this game in in real life and i think
i'm on day five or six or something like
that what's great about dead trigger is
this is the way to do a high quality 3d
title for mobile they've been very
clever in the way they actually reuse a
relatively small number of environments
do a whole variety of different missions
and they've managed to fit the game into
about a hundred megabytes which is great
now this however and I love how they
have an ad for shadowgun they do that
out rocks but here's the one problem
with his ad I mean seriously all right
so so so the one thing is we're gonna do
something cool enough like have an ad
for your other game dude show show show
them so the people this game show some
love on you guys that's one thing um
another thing is is back button support
I'm hitting the back button right now
you know it's nothing is happening here
going back button yeah this is just so
you know yeah so you know it's like it's
like it's like they never watched the
show you know which is which is amazing
right by not we get it you're awesome
you know from Europe you can do things
differently yeah but not the freaking
back button yeah you do not mess with
that pal so that's one thing another
another thing about the game is it
actually does have kind of limited back
button support on the main page when you
actually get back to it it's like
mission field also also guys so this is
only is the dress and read the
application blog and what it comes down
to is that this is a great game you know
you should all try it out into a plate
you're gonna have a lot of fun with it
yeah but it will not be a featured app
and google play until they because some
of these the Google yeah because the
Google Play QA team is gonna look at
this and just laughing it yeah of course
we're gonna nominate we're gonna we're
gonna work with these guys because we
think they're awesome we think that it
should be featured in Google Play but
they're gonna have to fix this stuff
before it gets featured totally and you
know and the game really is awesome and
the other thing that people now will say
a lot of people have been commenting on
google play that hey this is a 99-cent
game and it expects me
to buy stuff oh it's pay me up yeah and
actually the reality the game is you can
grunt your way through this game without
buying anything as far as I can tell
maybe there is we know what hey yeah get
over yourselves yeah I know this is my
machine dollar game yeah it's it's this
would have sold for 15 bucks on xbox
live and you know it yeah this 99 cents
is a pretty good deal it's a really good
deal I had to be honest I'm now on
diocese at day 70 something of the game
and i still only paid the nineteen cents
a part of the reason I did that was I
wanted to see you know could I actually
get through the entire game with 99
cents that's still left to will still
don't really know whether that's true
but you know as you go weeks go by i'll
try to update you guys order again for
you just in terms of yeah you know the
way you perceive things yeah how many
hours are in a day 26 so I that answers
my question thank you actually there's
only four hours for sleep that's what it
really comes down to it so um yeah well
you know I knew I know that you that
since you've had a child actually for
hours of sleep is a luxury so in any
case yeah but uh so what I'll continue
reporting back and also I hope you come
back with this game when they fix some
of these things because it is awesome so
that is dead trigger now other games
that we are playing now this game is not
on the main screen here because it was
already installed but this mine yes so
does no I'm gonna take this out of the
other thing here okay um okay radiant
defense is every year or two there comes
a game that I have to finish I almost
never finish a game and in this
particular case it was radiant defect
you know the last there's a lot to come
out I have finally finished already
started every level nice uh so I love
tower defense games i think tower
defense games are great mmm this one in
particular really really caught my eye
so it was free to download um before you
are going to it i think you've
disconnected the hdmi cable oh what Oh
how's that that's but I'm wonderful okay
very cautious with these mini hdmi
cables micro HDMI cables yeah yeah
but what's really really interesting
about this game is that unlike the soap
well let's let's go ahead and get past
the sort of cheesy humorous sections
here they actually are pretty funny or
is good yeah well it's right up at the
like Captain Underpants level exactly
just where we like us work we like it
okay I so so so like many tower defense
games your enemies will come on a path
what makes this one interesting is that
you will set the path by building blocks
now a lot of games will let you set the
path your alter the path by building
towers but in this case you can't build
towers on the path you have to build
towers on these existing black squares
but you also get a certain number of
these black squares that the blocks to
set yourself so if I set up these
modules I can actually lengthen or alter
the path and this turns out to be one of
the major innovated in a well it turns
out to be want to major strategy now you
have to think about there's a lot of
levels where you're absolutely hopeless
unless you've built the correct path but
if you have built a path that makes
sense that you know for instance you've
got aliens coming at you from two
different areas you need to build a path
so that one of them takes so long that
you get it second right instead of
getting both of them at the same time
and the the other innovation the other
thing that I think is really interesting
is that towers miss the towers actually
have aim I and they rotate around at a
fixed speed so sometimes and you're
seeing it right now every now and then
one of those bullets will just miss one
of the enemies so you have to be really
careful about your tower placement
because you don't want to make it so
they have to rotate around really quick
you don't want to make it so the shots
are hard for instance if you place a
tower where the aliens are coming past
it then it's going to be harder for it
to make the shots because they're coming
faster whereas if you place a tower so
the enemies are coming towards it it's a
lot easier to make a shot and i love the
graphic style this game
the style is great yeah hexa just
doesn't especially with all our games
but you're radiant defense i think is
the pinnacle of what they've done with
this style I think that's I think it's
brilliant and it you know you know you
you need it look at one of their games
and you immediately say oh that's a hex
Akane yeah that's just it so hope that's
how it's pronounced but uh heck soggy
high kicks ha gay that's right it could
be yeah there you go yeah so in the UK I
believe so um well we're going for hexa
JH yes sir so yeah the the the graphics
are great they've got this really cute
cartoony style but it's that it's not
too cute yeah I all of the enemies and
the weapons are really well-rendered
they all have their own behaviors that
keep you engaged but on top of that they
they just have a really deep strategy
and a a really interesting monetization
model so this is one of those games
where you buy upgrade packs and i have
to admit i bought all the upgrade pack
so when i say a 3 started i did three
start but i had to do i had to buy all
the upgrade packs let me show you what
they've got you can get so yeah yeah so
basically let's say that I want this the
the best weapon in the game by far
mm-hmm is the ballistic missile sarofim
missile launcher okay yeah and the
reason such a great weapon is because
the it they're seeking okay so if they
miss they'll come around again I thought
is it sarofim the the name of the the
like Pharisees or something I don't know
it's good thinking of Sadducees serafim
or not they were they were just like
cherubim that's why one of those
Kabbalistic angels that's why they were
called they were there the Kabbalistic
group all right size so I just I was
just curious if there was if there was
some mythological reference there that I
was missing this I think we've both
missed so if I want to unlock this they
they're gonna sell me the explosive pack
and I think I don't know it's like a
dollar ninety-nine ourselves it really
where you can get the science pack hmm
which gives you power blades which are
them because you know how there's
there's always like one enemy that gets
away from you and he's like got one hit
point left but he still kills you well
you put a power blade in front of your
base and he runs into it and boom
awesome awesome yeah incredible stuff
just really fun so the other thing
that's what that I love about it um I
think you do have to buy it if I
remember I think it's one of these oh
maybe not maybe not it's i think it's
it's actually in there to begin with is
uh they have a specific type of tower
that doesn't do any damage but if an
enemy dies near it it doubles your money
nice i like that so you get into these
really interesting strategies where
you're not just trying to kill all the
aliens you're trying to kill them in the
right place so you can get the most
money in the way they score is like so
like many games that I enjoy they give
you an interest bonus between between
rounds right I which gives you an
incentive to spend the least money
possible now they capped that at five
hundred dollars so right so if you get
more than 500 you're not going to get
any more interest which is good you know
makes sense yeah but then what they do
for your score is they take all the
enemies you killed and then all the
money you have left and they multi they
have a multiplication factor so if you
want to get a huge high score on this
game which I haven't I think the top 10
scores are all about 20 million I think
three starting every level I think I
might have broken two million Wow but so
says the moral of the story is this game
monetized well enough the Ian went and
bought everything in the game so it's
probably one like own money yeah not my
google credit card yes and so this is
probably one that's yeah this is
probably one that said that's worth
looking at if you're studying you know
what's a decent story now of course you
know that that's Indian may not reflect
everyone's taste but this all really I'm
very different yeah it's a lot of fun
and it not only did it give me a reason
to buy but did you notice how good their
merchandising is there not just saying
it's not a stupid little list of things
that you can buy that's dull and boring
it's a they sought to you like I their
mock
marketing it within the game to me as
the player of the game which is awesome
yes exactly you want to do you know this
is not the place to cut corners right
game is when you're actually and also
some point I you know like you know
4,000 radiant bucks or something like
that yeah um you know that this is what
you're doing this is what you get and
but they've they've put some nice
graphics they've given them creative
names that make me think oh yeah I want
that hack and even just saying it's a
pack yeah for being kind of cool people
who feel really nickeled and dimed by
these games you know this is this is a
great strategy and actually I think even
if even if you are selling these things
individually I think the idea of also
selling them in packs is really
appealing yeah and especially you know
I've I mean what i really want shadowgun
to do actually is have an upgrade that
turns out that that doubles the amount
of coins you get for everything in the
game and then turns everything you had
to buy with gold which is which is the
which is the quote slow currency that
you basically don't get during the game
into something you can buy with coins
basically unlocking the entire game into
something that you can just grind
through for like seven or eight dollars
right I think this is this is actually a
nine or ten dollar game mmm I which
absolutely I is in line with the
enjoyment that I got out of it had a lot
of fun could have spent nothing mm-hmm
and still had a lot of fun but I getting
each pack just it just you really
increase my enjoyment exactly exactly
now here's here's a question for you by
the way about pricing okay would you
rather get something that is fifty
percent off mm-hmm or something where
you get fifty percent more free you know
usually it's that's an interesting
question I want both and because your
hand galloping you'll probably get it
but let's pretend you're me no I mean I
I think I think honestly fifty percent
more free makes a lot of sense when it
comes to you know monetization in the
game I was like if it is it there's only
a certain number of people who are going
to monetize and if you're and if you can
make those users feel like they're
getting value for their money and make
them spend a little bit more my
suspicions is you're going to monetize
better so here's the thing i was just
reading this in the Economist this
morning because that's what
read when I brush my teeth in the
morning right and they had an article
that said they did some studies on this
and people would rather get fifty
percent more free you get fifty percent
off even though you know let's do the
math yeah yeah good money yes fifty
percent more free is thirty-three
percent off the price mm-hmm so uh yeah
just an interesting thing but yeah
definitely people like to feel like
they're getting a better deal yeah and I
think I think really that's a key thing
one of the you know we're working with
with you know wind up Knight beginning
of the game he pops up this dialog and
says boom you know you can unlock the
entire game for a one-time only price of
blah and after you know right after I
think you're after the second level or
something like that and it was his most
popular purchase in the game you know
people at one he's she demonstrated
value to they'd already understood what
they were getting in terms of in terms
of gameplay and it was so awesome once
you an unlocked the entire game to not
have to worry about that then you could
just spend your money on all the really
cool upgrades he did in the game and it
was it was very cool so I got you know
you know what is absolutely the biggest
draw monetization wise you know
everybody should do this this is this is
what we have discovered over and over
again the biggest draw is something
that's time limited mm-hmm where I have
spent my money so I spend my money on
things that I truly enjoy mm-hmm but
there are times when I have spent more
money than I was going to for instance i
bought platinum packs of cards on that
evening a big win hockey and right right
really enjoyed that still need to call
those guys and ask him why my team
doesn't work anymore maybe because I
spend too much money on it but the game
simply was not intended for a game of
your caliber that's Andrea and your
wallet size no yeah so yeah exactly
that's it anyway yes if you see me on
big win hockey I will kick your ass why
I have money mm-hmm it's not that much
money but probably more money than most
people when you spend on conf urgell
cards let's put it let's put this in in
real terms I'm stupid with my money
anyway my point is that um that the
platinum cards were on sale there were
fifty percent off for a week
I and I have no idea whether that's
whether they even stop that after weeks
but it got me iie and then and actually
a time-limited offers are great and not
only that it you know sport you know
people do kind of two things one is to
have an item that's only available
during that period period of time you
know in general and the second thing is
to have an offer or you know our sale
that's home that's only built for the
time periods those are both great also
activities tournaments anything you can
do to make the game more alive will get
will get people i guess i think actually
know what it was i'm wearing the
cheesehead and so you had it make fun of
yourself this time because i've just I
basically basically once you have the
nanny's head you're everything that I
always wanted you to be I have no
further criticism haha I've got the
beard I have the cheese head we're all
good alright so let's go on to our next
game God you didn't wear that she said
without a beard yeah would have been
disgusting yeah I know I know alright so
we do actually have that you've been
well you've been playing one other thing
I haven't we should probably get so
let's get let's get to the real let's
get to the real game should we do tiny
hak-su tiny ha I'll tell you this uh
when I saw this I'm like this is either
a game about it a little bitty bird or
it's gonna be about skating and that's
awesome thank God it's about
skateboarding that's what gone so uh
yeah this is odd this is a game that is
about skateboarding and you know
honestly it's it's fun it does have some
weird glitches occasionally like you
just saw there but basically your job is
to play tiny Hawk here is is this is
8-bit retro style but it's it's really
retro style it's not it's not uh you
know it's it's like you get the dream
right alone is much higher than you get
on ya in most retro games now you
basically can do two things you can jump
and you can go down so that's and that's
that and you and the goal is to get to
the end and to try to collect all of the
cans of whatever those are and what are
those I think they're there they're cans
of random soft drink I think of some
sort of energy beverage maybe it looks
like it you know I don't know but and
sometimes it's actually really hard to
to jump you have to kind of figure out
and you can't actually you know change
your direction so it is sort of like
this
endless runner / with the skate
skateboarding pair you can bounce off
the wall but you know you got that
exactly but you found off wall day so
that's the hdmi assets it's a little
time to put this back into its into it
stand just gonna so I'm really gonna
help just as I'm less likely to pick it
up and I'm less likely to jostle we just
switch the camera to for just a second
um because i just want to mention that
um that this looks totally dorky go
ahead and play the game thanks diet plan
plan all right so right so how ya how
dorky is that my dork really is right on
i'm alright just anyone does anyone
understand the door crew is strong
reference i don't know all right well
you have a picture in picture for camera
too yeah when'd you make that while
you're screwing around over here pretty
much right oh you are so much better at
this stuff than I am I don't know why
security yeah yeah exactly well you do
have a win7 so oh that would it's being
called these days oh you missed that
whole discussion I did I ready oh
alright we'll stop with the inside jokes
now okay so tiny Hawk verdict is what do
they do wrong I actually have not found
anything significant they do wrong um
you know the game the game does the
correct thing with the back key that
Dane Kane does the correct thing with
audio yeah I mean wrong as you go so as
far as as far as getting I I think that
they're the game itself can be a little
frustrating it is it is a native game
there's I don't see any particular
reason why it has to be other than they
you know my suspicion is that native
game you mean indicating its it is a non
DK game well it's marmalade game it's a
marble-like game exactly but I mean you
know that for the for the most part
they're they're doing right thing I
would say you know this is the only
thing if there was anything that I like
even allows you to continue the game by
hitting the continue button like you
know they've really understood the flow
and the way it should be there's any if
i if i didnt pick this looks like a
dialogue and i might expect hitting the
back key actually gets rid of it Rob
yeah yeah but you know but if they saw
pocket GDC you know what they're
probably thinking is we have options
and then our takut I owe you change that
and said you know what that other option
wasn't very good yeah yeah but anyway
but but in general I actually I actually
think I mean the fact that you can just
immediately continue like that is
awesome yeah I'm really impressed so
we're gonna we're going to go ahead and
nominate this yeah I'll tell you what I
think is going to happen I think what's
going to happen is that people are gonna
like this I don't know I mean we've got
a few a few people on the editorial
board that might frown on it but in
general the 8-bit stuff I if it's a good
game we like it but a lot of times it
won't be featured immediately yeah and
the main reason is that we're still
worried that your average Google Play
subscriber is not going to understand
the 8-bit motif they're not going to see
it as an O Maj they're going to see it
as something that either looks ugly to
them or reflects badly on the platform
but I'll tell you on javaris he does our
merchandising is huge retro gamer yeah
and all of this any of you put together
the indie games yes yeah yeah the ndm
selection last week and we're really
hoping to do a retro games collect yeah
very much want to do that and this would
be a perfect perfect one for that I
think the only issue really with with
the game is it can get a little
frustrating at times um because I bed
that that is all about red for games it
is you're not tearing your hair out on
retro game that it's not truly right
that's actually I lost all of my hair
mm-hmm so uh except for this piece in
the back yeah um so uh I just touched
Dan's hair I now I felt so tired all
right so next next game we're looking at
is let's get a awesome that okay sure
all right oh so awesome is a game that
is going to hopefully show up in
portrait yes way thank you dr. hdmi so
and an end to a sous for actually
putting this really awesome hdmi upset
set of settings in so up awesome yeah
I'm gonna play like this which looks
even dorkier than what was then what you
can go back to camera two jajaja just
turkey this actually looks but again
this is this is my my goal of trying to
keep the hdmi cord Ian micro HDMI is not
meant for the
who wants to hold their device tickle it
around and play games it is meant for it
sitting on a table so if anybody wants
to release a tablet with a BNC
connection we're all over that yeah
absolutely I like take my money yes
exactly that's so all right so what
awesome is actually by the way Red Hood
do we have a previous for camp today oh
really yeah oh well 70 bad for be in C
cable so awesome awesome is again that's
actually i think it's i think is a game
that's great for kids if I had a kid I
would totally encourage them to play
this game the goal is to actually some
up numbers and in this case it's I'm is
11 you can see on up on the top left
hand corner of the screen and I the goal
is to drop these things to get them to
match up to 11 not in nine know those
will match up to 11 however eight and
three will I can drop that on and boom
now that goes away so it teaches kids
basic arithmetic tables as well as
teaches them you know well gamer elite
skills I guess because it always a look
it no the Sun will change so like now I
mean you know and at some point you just
have to say I'm just going to drop them
right there's nothing i can do none of
these are going to add up you know and
you only have a limited number of those
retries and so there is a certain amount
of luck involved here what's even cooler
if you can get an awesome we're both add
up to 11 I really wish we could play the
sound effects but actually can I can I
simulate the sound effect yes you can
you can I so Oh 12 so now it's switched
to 12 and now you'll see whether I can
actually add anything to 12 which I
can't except the thing is we don't sound
enough like just laid-back California
surfer dude no you also can rotate
awesome bogus did yes you can also
rotate these like that so ocean kid I
totally screwed I could have made an
awesome there but instead i'm just going
to drop it because unfortunately all
right but it goes thanks so right now
we're now actually testing really to see
whether i can add which is which is
questionable but it's actually being
nice it's giving me things that'll
letter along exactly allowing me to get
rid of that likes tall stack there
alright looking that'll work so i still
haven't managed to get
a quote-unquote awesome yet but as you
can see the game is cool and yeah I
think actually it's going to help teach
kids arithmetic which I really like
there's not a lot of games that I see
out there that actually have what I
would consider to be a model the
educational component to them so yeah I
I liked it the game doesn't do anything
particularly wrong it looks actually
quite good honest how about the only
thing that we ran into be this game and
I never actually managed to figure out
why it wasn't showing up on a Galaxy
Nexus late yeah we were really curious
about that because we looked at the
game's listing and the only thing that
they were filtering on was ET c 1 which
everything should I yeah exactly so I'm
not so it was going on but it doesn't it
doesn't actually show up on a Galaxy
Nexus I will say this that filtering on
etc1 is it's it's there's no there are
like I think maybe two devices our
membership that don't support ECCC yeah
but no sir but it's in every yeah
exactly but you know if that's really
the reason why I stopped showing up we
need to figure that out so that's
awesome it is a really cool game I
definitely want to nominate it the other
thing I love about this is the off in
their title mmm is totally in the dare
to keep kids off drugs bond yes in the
80s exactly and that they'd show that
for just a second there right mm-hmm
yeah so yeah here yeah he totally
totally is yeah it's like I Universal it
does need to have needs to have a little
period next to each one of them so it
could be some sort of acronym that would
be so cool that would be so much yeah so
um so yeah one thing once they won 1
review comment for you guys but overall
you know the game the game is great and
good job guys really you know down a lot
to say about that the final one we
actually are officially looking at is
craft years and right so this was an
interesting game I it's I I didn't I
didn't know what to expect when I loaded
it up um I wasn't super happy with the
way it looked on phones honestly um and
but mostly it wasn't bad it was just
that on my galaxy nexus all these
buttons were just a little small yeah it
definitely they definitely I definitely
feel
like there is there even a little
smaller tablet yes I would yeah i think
if you could inflate by maybe twenty
percent i think you'd be there yeah
that's that was definitely my feeling
when i was playing it the game is cool
actually it's a game in which you then
you build things and then you actually
fight things with the things that you
build and and if you like taking lots of
objects and and fun looking all over to
find them and and figuring out how to do
things it's actually really fun and it's
sort of like an easier to discover
version of minecraft in a way I mean the
yeah the crafting and defense mechanic I
mean because you know you'll do things
like you'll pick up a log and make a
club out of it then you'll Club a tree
to death I'm not actually sure how that
works but you'll club down a tree yeah
you Club down a tree and then you'll
club it's the John Wayne ranks and
you'll plug it a club it's plank club
it's planks into sticks exactly and you
might need sticks and planks to build
something sometimes you also get a
little bit of straw which you can also
which well maybe you right you'll use
that to build a fire which is magical
because I thought you needed wood for a
fire but apparently straws all that's
good enough I then you can also club oh
no I'm sorry you can't Club stones you
need to get a statement you get it Flint
yeah the magic act and the flinching oh
add a bond from the vine in a vine to
vine tree exactly and uh yeah so a but
you can see I mean it ends up being
kinda just proven we both play through
the tutorial awesome so uh almost lost
my cheese there so uh yeah yeah so the
one thing I would say we can't really
show demonstrate this is this game does
have music on the lockscreen oh yeah
yeah which would make me sad abeba
that's like no one watches our show yeah
yeah so um so yeah you know fix that and
I think it's actually an interesting
game to feature I'm really I'm really
curious what the team would think about
it so you know I think it's decent I
mean you know it's not a novel game and
there are other games like this but I
will say it was a little novel in the
sense that I went through the entire
tutorial and it didn't ask me to buy
anything so then what kind of a you know
for this type for this particular genre
not being nickel dime was actually kind
of it ya know it did bring up an ad and
I will say the one bug that I found in
the game is when i clicked on the ad it
took me into into google play to buy
something i clicked back and i never got
the game back so well and this is a
little problem yeah it's it's it's very
common to mess up the transitions when
your when your app loses focus when you
app pauses or stops you really need to
make sure that you save where you are
and do everything you can to make it
quick to get back in it I noticed this
too like I locked my phone and then went
back in and it has to reload again and
it's it's a real pain now on Honeycomb
above you can you can use the API what's
the API again said do not lose your
context I'm not sure how tiny could end
up sand tiny village ends up showing up
here also that was it sometimes when I
randomly click on the screen even though
I don't see an ad it just randomly goes
there haven't figured that one out but
yeah that up quite a full version so
this doesn't this doesn't actually pop
up full screen but what I ended up
happening when i was in game and this
earth there was actually an in-game
added to this and i hit the back key to
get back out and then i was stuck
forever oh really yeah but that's hasn't
it doesn't have when you buy worry you
need to watch out for that yeah but but
right the in-app purchase is always
gonna pop up as a dialogue on on the
ballot yeah right you know I kind of
wish we'd do that on the phone too yeah
it's kind of a it's kind of a mixed bag
honestly in terms of in terms of how
good it is the advantage of it popping
up full screen is it the system is
guaranteed to have enough memory to
actually launch the Play Store the yes
but the advantage of it not popping up
full screen it is that it's not going to
try to reclaim your yeah and ninety
percent of time I mean there are a few
games that we've found that where the
Play Store and your app really can't
coexist but in general you know the
issue is what's the plate if the place
where needs more memory what's it going
to kill first is it going to kill like
10 random things that are tables rising
kill anything the rush is what is it
what is the Android platform going to
kill off as it tries to free up i'm
sorry i meant the
yeah exactly the Play Store client yeah
yeah the fight so it's what is it what
is when they struck when the Android
platform is trying to try to make room
for that place to our client what's it
going to kill was gonna say huh this is
one really big application has taken
hundreds of megabytes or am i under to
the background now so I'm going to kill
it off so that's a stay tuned on that
because I think we're going to maybe
make some progress there uh yeah but but
for right now the lesson to be gleaned
from this is if you've got anything that
hides your app whether it's an ad or an
in-app purchase or you know like a some
sort of tapjoy or whatever I mean offer
wall yeah any of those things if they're
in a different process and they need
more memory it could result in your
process stopping so you need to be
really careful about testing that sort
of thing and making sure that your
process can resume in a way that's not
going to annoy the user absolutely so
the final thing I wanted to actually go
over was this call of Atlantis which
isn't I know before we hit call that
lattice I just wanted to mention we did
have a back-up beer and since I think
we're oh no I'm done and you're not good
good is a thousand IV use it is hannahs
nine point eight percent alcohol but I
wanted to share this with you because i
know that actually right after this
meeting you've got a meeting with the
wit ya acta the vista people from call
of atlantis yeah yeah exactly so which
is by the way completely coincidental
yes we don't use we i was actually so
call of atlantis was really fun so it
was interesting because call bill Ennis
came came to us and and it actually was
a game that was letterboxed and then I
said to the guys been like look you know
this game looks like it was not designed
to run it anything other than a PC and
can you guys do something about it and
most developers when I say this is under
like no it was not designed and we're
not going to touch it and you know what
every other designers like it that way
yeah our design but but but they
actually came and said all right let's
think about it and so what they've done
as you can see here there is actually
stuff the game originally ended in the
middle of those columns on the left and
right hand side of the screen and they
simply extent they added additional
graphics and then they extended it with
this little bored so all that marble
marble II tough skin stuff on the left
and the right
was not there it was just black before
exactly it is just black and and and and
it was funny because I first I first
looked at I said well you know I it's
not what I exactly necessarily wanted
them to do but as I actually played both
versions the game side-by-side and i
realize i played this more and more
having it fill the full screen and it
does actually fill the full screen
during during various parts like the
load screen it actually does go full
screen there and it just felt that much
better and it was a real surprise to me
you know i mean we've always said we've
always said that this is we wanted
people to try to use the full screen but
in this game even making a relatively
minor change like adding a lot
background graphic that could extend and
not changing any other part of the
gameplay made an enormous difference the
experience to someone who's using it
really made it feel like i was playing
some it was meant for my device you know
and this this brings up an interesting
point because we've we've talked a lot
about different screen aspect ratios and
isn't it isn't it yes this is the barrel
aged bourbon 11 wow it is so it's a beer
that's been aged in bourbon barrels so
another thing I'll tell you when we
first got this game all of no hang on or
even you you can always interrupt me
with beer but you get in trouble with
other thing okay anyway the point is
that we know it can be frustrating to
deal with different aspect ratios but
there's always some way to do it that
isn't going to just completely suck you
know sometimes you can you can stretch
your game some games stretch really well
some games don't but you can add a
little bit too to either side you know
sometimes it's just as simple as hey you
had your scoring area your head over the
top of the game and now there's some
area above that that's just blank why
don't just move your heart up exactly so
the the one thing you don't want to do
and this is this is where I was getting
to is try and game the system by
defining compatible screens and making
really really specific aspect ratios for
each set of screens because you know
what's happened to all the people that
declared on compatible screens today
they're not showing up on this that's
right none of them show up on the nexus
7 you know why because we didn't
about it exactly no more the problem is
that the Nexus 7 is a geometry that's
never been seen before in Android it's a
7 inch device well it's 1280 by eight it
isn't most importantly it is a dpi that
is definitely seen before that's what I
meant it's not it's quite a court TV DPI
yeah that's it well I we haven't really
named it it's 213 DPI so that's the you
said the number I know I know so um so
don't use compatible screens is the
moral of that yeah if you can possibly
all right go back to I know you're just
really talks on all of alanis so so on
so one thing we notice when you're first
play in the game is that the fonts were
very very low resolution and it's
interesting because when a font is
really really low resolution your I
tries to focus that font it tries to say
because it looks blurry yeah and it just
makes its makes you strain to read all
the text as if you're expecting it to
somehow you know get in if your eyes it
tricks your iron into actually trying to
get it to focus when it can't and so
what Ruth is that's actually just Dan
he's into bifocals and we have it Thank
You Ian now back to the game so we we so
we asked them me he said look you know
can you do anything about the fonts and
they did and honestly the game is much
much more playable it's right and they
even though the background is still the
equal low resolution you but don't even
really noticed that the back for the
most part the backgrounds in much lower
resolution than the font in the
foreground but the whole game feels a
lot more crisp it didn't take that much
more space and it made a huge difference
in the game play and to put it more
technically what you want to do is watch
your your high frequency art so fonts
are always expected to be high frequency
you can get away with lower frequency on
other pieces of art you know on your
backgrounds for instance you can't
always get away with it but in general
you can but you know basically you need
to you need to look at your game on
different displays and ask yourself
especially on
the 720p or even I when it releases the
new 1080p tablets look at them and ask
yourself does your game actually still
look good and if it doesn't you might
want to start considering switching up
some art you just did doing a set of
larger bitmap spring and that's and
that's it and that's mostly what they
did I mean there but there are some they
didn't bother to do and for the most
part you don't notice them and I think
the key thing is be strategic you know
you know you don't actually need to
necessarily change every piece of art in
order to get something feeling like a
real tablet app but all of a sudden this
app which really felt very low
resolution very outdated all of a sudden
feels like a modern application and so
really does it looks very crisp from
back here yeah it looks great night I
see what you mean about the backgrounds
aren't necessarily the same resolution
but I think it's a perfect trade off
what they've done is they've taken the
elements that are relatively small but
high frequency and put a lot of effort
into making those sharp and they've
taken the elements that are lower
frequency but really really large and
they've kept those at a lower effective
resolution which means they use less
memory without actually disturbing the
user experience exactly and so you know
that's and I think that so I again I
part of reason I want to highlight this
was because I really like the trade off
so they made I think they think they
need to made some very smart decisions I
will say the only thing that left that I
really really don't like about this game
is their iconic we can go you can see
that I kind of paint screen it just
makes me sad yeah because Android icons
are not supposed to be you know rounded
cornered thing let's talk about all of
these icons because every single one of
them makes me sad they're all let's just
talk about how each of them could be
better dead trigger does not need a
rounded rectangle around you no reason
why not just put LMK you know an outline
around the letters yeah it'd be so cool
of it what's gonna have yeah cool like
glowing outline in the back of red and
the next one crossers yeah say the same
basic deal I why not just a pickaxe in
Flint why does it have to have a
background yeah the next one is well
okay those guys
little and so the next one but still
yeah why he hug you don't even need to
have I just have an alpha background
yeah exactly and awesome definitely
definitely an alpha background would be
awesome you only need the three you only
need the three numbers because remember
we know that there are a lot of
guidelines out there and we know that a
lot of times you you go with you know a
particular lead skew or a particular you
know maybe it's the device that your
boss owns or whatever and they want
everything to look like that particular
OS but remember that Android users
bought Android for a reason they usually
love their Android device and they want
it to look like Android and if you look
at those icons on the bottom which are
which are which are mostly I Android
system icons of the screen you can see
that that they all have unique shapes
and part of the way that people
recognize them is their shapes you
recognize that the browser's at circle
so it actually gives the user something
else do right Lou into now some of these
that you know sometimes it's really like
like for instance I think YouTube
YouTube's logo has always looked like
that yes because it would be no browser
right so even though if if somewhere to
someone were to come with to us with
this icon and say does this look like an
Android icon honestly we'd say well no
but if it's part of your branding if
it's part of the way your brand looks
all right but especially when it's
obviously not and and calling the land
is a great example of this call of
Atlantis has a brand that's that's
defined by this circular thing and it's
well it's got this dragon in the corn
right right so it does thing with a
dragon in the corner ok well the dragon
in the corn is just a badge right yeah
it's probably I've just to you know
everybody's got badges yeah that's that
well that's that's their play Rex brand
right and then and then the game the
game is actually the circle well it
would actually be really cool to just
have it just have it be a circle you
know and and and we have full alpha and
these in these support in these icons
and it can look really really great and
it doesn't actually need to have you
know this this thing on the background
so you know that's a general call the
developers you know think of your brand
is very very important think about how
you can make your application stand out
on Android by taking advantage
back that you can use funky shapes yep
absolutely and you'll and the really
nice thing about this is that instead of
having just a featureless set of uniform
rounded rectangles your user will be
looking at things we're not only the
picture but also the outline of your
icon will become a visual cue to them to
know where your application is and what
what that icon stands for so in general
if you can and we realize that sometimes
design departments are tough to convince
but if you can convince them that they
don't want the rounded rectangle you can
often get a better more memorable icon
on Android absolutely so what so that so
we're almost done for it for today we
are so out of time loudly gave rato 45
minutes and we have just taken 56 you
know why just work right so in any case
so definitely keep nominating stuff to
the forum we really really appreciate
all the time you guys put in there we
really really appreciate all the time
you guys put in actually writing games
we've been so happy honestly with with a
lot of the games that have come out to
Google Play it's a great yeah you know
this year we have seen so much great
stuff on Google Play we've still got a
few developers that that we really want
to bring over but in general the the
quality is such that you know three
years ago we were like what are we gonna
feature this week and now it's like oh
my god how what are we going to reject
because they're all so good yeah it's
great to see everyone everyone's taking
to the platform you know to me I think I
think this having a nexus 7 is a
reference device for people to play off
of its great i mean what's awesome is
this is 199 dollar device in the u.s.
it's a low-end advice it's a hundred and
ninety nine dollars and it's it's
slightly more capable than an xbox one
yeah it's I've amazing almost I mean
modulo some custom software it sits in
the League of the ACS transformer prime
which has been our top performing get to
device for a long time and it's only 200
bucks so which which just blows my mind
now and i would say that i'm gonna buy
one for my
wife but if I bought one for my wife
she'd be pissed because I just spent 200
bucks I need to find a way to get it for
free and then show so I think what I'm
gonna do is get one for myself for free
and then buy one and give her the one
that was free and say it was free right
exactly exactly so you you yeah you my
wife's like that anyway but yeah so uh
an absolutely and you know it was it
really doesn't watch this program board
yeah sometimes she does actually but um
the other thing that's really cool about
this device is the tiger three paths
platform and and I so I don't want to
massively pimp the target three platform
it has its good part good size it has a
bad sides you know it's a platform but
but um you may have noticed that some
companies are betting heavily on it up
in the gaming space well here's a chance
to get a depth get really cheap exactly
I don't know why we're pimping this so
heavily because we like nobody's gonna
pay us for doing I know I know we're
gonna get a class on the guys in vid
that I just really love it yeah we love
you all it's just one of those things
where we're like yeah you know phones
come out and sometimes we're like super
happy like oh yeah this is great but let
me speak frankly for a moment this is in
the history of Android a lot of times
something will come out and we're like
you know what that's awesome but I can
go to the store and get something a
competing product that's just as good
for a either a lower price or maybe the
same price but objectively it's slightly
better in some ways and this changes all
of that this is the first product that
we've shipped where the its competitive
on price and performance and pretty much
everything else and we've had a lot of
fun playing with we've had development
devices in for about two months now I've
been carrying them with us or we've been
sharing them with with developers in our
lab and every time I pick one up I'm
like
I'm really happy to worship in this
device yeah it's it's a it's a warm and
fuzzy feeling to to be proud of
something that you're shipping like this
and I'll take from furman developer
perspective the other thing that's great
about it is that Nvidia is performance
tools work out of the box on this device
no way yeah which is all no way so
that's awesome yeah so basically all
right so I was on the xbox 360 launch
team and I think that since then this
the first device that I've been just as
excited about awesome maybe well maybe
they're quiet but you went out of the
desert for that i did i did i was i was
there freezing in the desert with
everyone else it was awesome it was a
good thing that they distributed
sweatshirts to us so so so in any case
that's it for today's Friday game review
again you know continue putting cool
stuff in the moderator we're going to
continue to mix it up a little I'm
hoping actually actually would love to
show you guys those those performance
analysis tools and they go maybe we'll
run a game through the ringer let us let
us know you can give us you can give us
feedback on our Google+ page and you can
give us feedback on YouTube but we
probably won't read it because let's
face it come on YouTube commenters come
on but yeah this but in general we want
to know what you think and we also want
to know what you'd like to see would you
like to see more technical info because
that's kind of our job where we're
engineers would you like to see just
more game reviews we can do that too we
are massive gamers what what's most
interesting to you anyway let's uh sign
off for now next week we will be back
with another beer and another set of
games love you all see you later